foreign
[Music]
gifted where are you I'm in a church
what are you serious we're looking for a
venue for the wedding you're going to
get married in a church I'm shocked you
didn't burst into flames as you cross
the threshold
to live in Arthur oh thank you I think
we should all go to Italy Italy whoa
we'll make it bib's Bachelorette a
bachelorette trip what are we doing I
think it's very romantic but it's also
nuts
what did they say the older The Vines
the sweeter the fruit oh yes we still
got it I'm delighted that you'll be
joining us tonight there's no problem
with four random women show up this is
Italy there's always room for random
beautiful women
is already quite amused
it's two bridles it's not Bridal enough
gorgeous someone else next
[Music]
move what are you doing that would be me
we're best friends for 50 years and you
married marriage my solo act is finally
coming to a close you're the bravest
person I know the only question is how
will we mess this all up I can't wait to
find out
is it too soon to talk about who we're
gonna eat first I think we all know
hey
[Music]
in her 70s end up getting married
she takes control of her own destiny
this is a bachelorette party no that
means we go see naked men
what's the protocol here where do I
stuff the dollar bills
ciao